so the first time I made Lobster R I was
a junior in college and I definitely sto
that Lobster here well technically I
didn't steal it but I did ring them up
as Peaches and so forgot what do you
want me to tell you I was in college I
boobster anyways it was 3:00 a.m. and I
had just gotten home from the water and
I was like oh I have lobster tails
in my fridge right now I know exactly
what to do I made them and I was shook
it took me maybe 10 minutes maybe mind
you I was drunk I was most of my videos
actually are filmed at like 3:00 a.m.
slash I had to C this video but if I
didn't you would have seen the time that
show that it was 2:42 a.m. when I was
tossing the Lobster in butter and lemon
juice and salt and pepper because I have
to keep and anyways so I made them and I
made them in a way that's in between a
main and Connecticut style BR but it's
so easy so worth it so good and it would
be like $40 in the restant